bonjour bienvenue dans l'entretien
aujourd'hui mon invité est Chirine et
Badi bonjour merci de vous exprimer sur
France 24 sur une Badi vous êtes avocate
vous avez été la première juge d'Iran
avant la Révolution islamique avant de
perdre le droit d'exercer ce métier lors
de l'instauration de la République
islamique qui vous avez reçu le prix
Nobel de la paix en 2003 pour votre
engagement près des plus démunis en Iran
et face à la pression vous avez dû
quitter l'Iran pour l'exil les
manifestations en Iran sont entrées dans
leur troisième mois selon vous est-ce
une révolution qui est en cours en ce
moment
absolument ce qui se produit aujourd'hui
en Iran et tourne une révolution dans le
sens plein du terme
cela fait trois mois en effet que les
Iraniens sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui même les lycéens et les
lycéens se sont joints à ce mouvement
alors il y a eu des grèves des grèves
des avocats notamment des actes
désobéissance civile avec des équipes de
de football ou de volley-ball qui
refusent de chanter l'hymne national
tout ça aussi fait partie de cette
révolution
[Musique]
en effet à présent cette contestation a
gagné toutes les couches de la société
tous les corps de métiers parce que cela
fait 43 ans qu'aucun des besoins du
peuple n'a été pris en considération par
le gouvernement et à chaque fois qu'une
protestation a été exprimée la riposte a
été faite par les balles et les
emprisonnements
à la racine de cette révolte il y a les
femmes la mort de Massa et minis c'est
le déclencheur mais c'est aussi vous
l'avez dit la somme de 43 ans de
discrimination être une Iranienne
aujourd'hui cela veut dire quoi
a été la goutte qui a fait déborder le
vase l'allumette craquée qui a mis le
feu aux poudres parce qu'en effet cela
fait bien longtemps que cette
discrimination continue et aujourd'hui
être une Iranienne c'est protester
contre cet état de fait c'est descendre
dans la rue c'est se battre c'est
prendre position et même celle qui ne
peuvent pas descendre dans la rue sont
dans leur foyer en train de préparer des
sandwichs de nourrir ce mouvement de
leur façon
la répression est d'une grande brutalité
près de 400 morts 15.000 arrestations
selon des ONG indépendantes et les
premières condames condamnations à mort
qui ont été prononcées dans des
tribunaux révolutionnaires pour faire
peur aux manifestants mais on a
l'impression que cette peur à la changer
de camp est-ce que vous partagez aussi
cette analyse
absolument votre impression est les
Iraniens n'ont plus peur ils sont
arrivés au bout de cette ligne qui est
poursuivait ils n'ont plus rien à perdre
et ils disent que quel que soit le prix
à payer il faut qu'ils arrivent à venir
à bout de ce régime je tiens à ajouter
qu'il y a aujourd'hui plus de 14000
arrestations à tel point qu'ils ne
savent plus où mettre les gens qui
arrêtent les plus présents sont saturés
ils commencent à avoir recours à
d'autres types de lieux de bâtiments
pour garder ces personnes là en
détention et parmi les morts les
victimes de cette répression on compte
plus de 50 enfants
la mort justement de qui en a peefala
qui a été tué à l'âge de 10 ans dans
l'ouest de l'Iran à bouleverser les
Iraniens et même au-delà des frontières
et ce dimanche 20 novembre marque aussi
la journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant des droits que n'ont pas les
enfants iraniens
en effet les droits des enfants ne sont
pas respectés en Iran il y a des
exécutions de mineurs que nous sommes en
train de dénoncer depuis de nombreuses
années il y a des mariages
d'enfants mineurs que l'on Marie il y a
de nombreux enfants surtout
issus des populations tribales qui ne
sont pas reconnus parce qu'ils n'ont
tout simplement pas de documents
d'identité donc il y a chez les baloutes
ou chez les ethnies du de la région du
Corazon des enfants dont l'existence
n'est tout simplement pas accès par
l'État iranien et pour ce qui est de
Kyon l'enfant
que vous évoquez il a été
assassiné par les forces de police de
l'État dans la rue et rien n'est fait
alors que sa photo est partout en Iran
que les Iraniens se sont beaucoup émus
de son sort l'UNICEF ne fait rien et n'a
pas voulu malgré mes appels répétés
encore hier prendre position et dénoncer
ce qui arrivait à cet enfant je tiens à
le déclarer ici que l'UNICEF a un bureau
en Iran mais qu'il n'est absolument pas
actif et encore aujourd'hui il ne prend
pas position pour les droits de ses
enfants
Nesrine surtout dès votre concert avocat
des droits de l'homme a été condamné à
38 ans de prison elle est actuellement
en résidence surveillée à Téhéran avec
une santé qui est très fragile elle
demande au monde d'être je cite les yeux
et les oreilles des Iraniens comment
faire pour l'être
toutes les informations toutes les
vidéos qui circulent en provenance des
rangs doivent être diffusés de la façon
la plus large possible il faut que
l'opinion publique il faut que les
peuples du monde entier soient informés
de la façon dont le gouvernement iranien
est en train de réprimer son peuple
comment on peut aujourd'hui aider les
Iraniens dans leur quête dans leur envie
de démocratie que peut faire le monde
lorsqu'ils appellent le monde à être
leur voix les aider concrètement que
peuvent faire les dirigeants du monde
le peuple iranien se bat depuis des
années pour accéder à la démocratie
c'est son devoir à lui seul de faire
venir cette démocratie et il a pris ce
chemin là ce que peut faire les
gouvernements étrangers c'est cesser de
soutenir le régime iranien cesser
d'assurer sa survie à la tête de ce pays
de ne plus participer à leur mise en
place dans ce régime et donc pour cesser
ses relations là il y a des mesures
simples qui peuvent être prises il faut
que tous les pays occidentaux retirent
leurs ambassadeurs d'Iran et renvoient
des ambassadeurs d'Iran sur leur
territoire il faut que les relations
diplomatiques et politiques avec l'Iran
passe du niveau des ambassades à un
niveau simplement consulaire ce serait
un geste de protestation très clair
contre la répression en Iran et contre
l'assassinat de citoyens innocents dans
ce pays une des manifestantes me disait
notamment on ne peut pas revenir en
arrière on ira jusqu'au bout est-ce que
vous sentez aussi cette détermination
des Iraniens est-ce que vous pensez que
cette fois ci aussi pète la bonne et
peut signifier la fin de ce régime
absolument il n'y a pas de retour en
arrière possible parce que le
gouvernement a commis des actes
impardonnables il est impossible de
revenir sur ses actes la violence a pris
des proportions inédites à titre
d'exemple dans la ville de maraba de
Kurdistan la répression est-elle les
vidéos que l'on reçoit en provenance de
cette ville au spectacle que c'est
difficilement croyable il est difficile
il est impossible maintenant de sortir
dans la rue dans cette ville les gens
sont systématiquement
cible de balles quand ils sortent dans
la rue et même quand il reste chez eux
les forces de police viennent tirer chez
à travers leurs fenêtre chez eux les
différentes personnes de mahaba dont
envoyer des vidéos où il monte qu'il
reçoive des gars de lacrymogène chez eux
et disent alors qu'on ne sort même plus
de chez nous on vient nous gazer dans
nos intérieurs dans notre maison donc
quand de tels violence sont commises par
un gouvernement il n'est plus possible
ça survie n'est plus possible il y a
quelques années vous aviez indiqué que
ce régime était de toute façon condamné
il est condamné à court terme donc très
prochainement
il me semble en effet que les événements
qui ont cours en ce moment en Iran sont
le début de la fin de ce régime
comment vous voyez l'avenir politique de
l'Iran est-ce que cet avenir pourrait
aussi s'appeler chérie nebady
gouvernement démocratique et laïque
c'est ce que le peuple iranien appelle
de ses vœux et exprime clairement donc
il est lira ses représentants dans des
élections libres et démocratiques si
jamais vous aviez un message à adresser
aux Iraniens qui vous regardent qui vont
regarder cette interview quel serait ce
message pour eux apporter votre aide à
porter votre soutien par tous les moyens
qui sont possibles à ces manifestants
qui sont dans la rue aujourd'hui en Iran
et qui sont en train de payer de leur
vie le prix de la liberté de ce pays
et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup sirène et Badi de vous être
entretenu sur notre antenne sur cette
situation en Iran
je vous remercie beaucoup de m'avoir
donné la possibilité de m'exprimer au
revoir
merci beaucoup à l'entretien à retrouver
sur nos antennes et sur notre site
Internet à très bientôt
[Musique]